hey I'm an Jones I host off-track which
is the ABCs nature podcast and today
we've got some salt water crocodile
videos I'm hoping no one gets killed
[Music]
let's watch some croc penis
[Music]
the placid bike is that what is it cold
I don't even know what's it cold
this film is called Lake Placid cheese
so the premise of this film is that
we're in Maine up in North America
beautiful spot lots of forest and
there's a saltwater crocodile that's
your first red flag film that is not
going to happen saltwater crocodiles
live in warm waters name like freezes
over in the winter movies are bizarre
because okay it's the wrong species in
the wrong place there is enough dangers
in the world to actually get them in the
right geographical location I don't know
anyone that would to try and study your
crop would get in the water with them
that is so incredibly dangerous and how
they do it for both croc control and to
do scientific monitoring is actually
have sort of trap setups with baits that
are closer to the edge of the water
crocodile would be able to see him
underwater because it's got a special
island so it would be able to see him
bumbling around it's really much more
likely that you will never see the croc
when it's checking you out that it will
be either you know almost completely
submerged or at it more of a distance
than you expect Crocs can stay submerged
for like three hours their heart slows
right down a little bit like one or two
times per minute
they reckon that this crocodile is a
hundred and fifty years old and that's
why it's so big it's basically
impossible that a crocodile would get
that big or that old just because you're
big doesn't mean you're old being big is
part of whatever the environmental
conditions that you find yourself in so
you might have a big territory with lots
of fish and that means that it allows
you to grow bigger but if you're all
densely packed in in a poor environment
that might be polluted fewer fish more
competition you're not going to get as
big rogue what's that dog doing there I
still don't understand why you've got a
dog on a croc tour but okay I'm pretty
sure that's a national park is well you
can't have dogs in national parks people
number one evil is a moral term and
morality is human right so you can't be
applying that sort of stuff
to nature that croc is just doing what
that croc wants to do which is eating
tourists but on a positive side it looks
like the right habitat for a saltwater
croc to be lurking it goes without
saying that that is incredibly important
right there is almost no chance of a
massive croc knocking a tourist boat up
and spewing people out into the water
like a boat is a huge thing compared to
even the biggest croc that boat thing
that's look at the boat is like
basically looks like it's got an
explosive under it
so I think that some of those kills made
it really look as if the crocodile was
just like eating like a whole human that
just doesn't happen for a start they
don't have the stomach capacity to do
that and it's not been documented that
they do that when they attack a human
they're much more likely to bury a piece
of prey and come back to it later
there's also no documentation that
indicates that like there's been four
human attacks in like 24 hours they'll
also go for things like turtles and fish
and crabs and all sorts of stuff
Crocodile Dundee I haven't seen this
since I was a kid she's gonna get
mosquito bites on her bum meek don't
work it's factually incorrect because
it's actually impossible to look that
sexy when you're in northern Australia
because you're always like sweaty and
disgusting in some ways it's actually
fairly accurate right because what would
have happened is she comes down to the
side of the water and she's you know
getting a drink and the crocodile would
have clocked her from quite a ways away
and then dive down approached in stealth
and come up in a surprise attack there's
two things though that stand out to me
that really silly as if that drink
bottle would be able to withstand the
1,500 kilograms of bite force from that
crocodile and on top of that it got the
drink bottle and it didn't get her that
is just not going to happen it'll get
her every time
don't kill the crocodile they're
protected don't approach the crocodile
just run away from the crocodile and
definitely don't try to put a knife
through the head of the crocodile all
right stop it there this is actually
pretty cool it's I mean it's a fake
crocodile but it gives you a really good
demonstration of what the head looks
like and it's got these big teeth that
you can see that are sort of terrifying
but some of them are actually visible
and sit outside the skin and that's one
of the ways that you can tell that it's
a saltwater crocodile and the way that
their jaws work the teeth actually have
you know little indentations so that
when the jaws close it all fits together
really beautifully it's really well
engineered one thing I noticed in all of
these movie
was that when the crocodile actually
attacked it made a warring sound and I
don't know if that's really realistic
I've never been attacked by a crocodile
so if you have or you've seen a
crocodile taking prey and know what type
of sound it makes please comment below
and if you've got a recording email it
to me I really want to hear it